>> WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
I'M CHRIS FITZPATRICK.
AND SADLY, TODAY, MANY PEOPLE
CAN'T SEEM TO AGREE UPON ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT'S
TEARING OUR COUNTRY APART.
WHAT'S BETTER?
ROCK MUSIC OR RAP.
AND SO --
♪♪♪
>> BUT FIRST, A HISTORY LESSON.
ROCK MUSIC WAS INVENTED BY
ELVIS PRESLEY.
IT WAS MADE FOR ALL COLORS OF
PEOPLE.
BUT GOOD ROCK MUSIC ONLY STARTED
MORE RECENTLY WITH BANDS LIKE
TEMPORARY FLAWED, WORTHY ESCAPE,
AND MY OWN BAND
CRIPPLED REJECTS.
WHO ARE QUICKLY BECOMING ONE OF
THE TOP FIVE BANDS.
RAP MUSIC IS NEWER, BUT
SOMETHING FEELS KIND OF OFF
ABOUT IT.
SO, WHICH ONE IS BETTER?
ROCK OR RAP?
I SPOKE TO A VERY DIVERSE GROUP
OF PEOPLE.
NOW THEY HAD SOME INTERESTING
THINGS TO SAY.
DO YOU LIKE ROCK MUSIC?
>> LOVE IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU LIKE BETTER, ROCK
MUSIC OR RAP?
>> ROCK MUSIC.
>> ROCK.
>> NEITHER IS BETTER.
MUSIC EXPRESSES WHAT YOU FE --
>> ROCK.
>> YOU LIKE ROCK MUSIC?
>> YEAH, ROCK.
>> ROCK MUSIC.
>> ROCK.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT RAP?
>> NAH, I DON'T LIKE RAP AT ALL.
>> TO ME IT'S JUST CRAP WITH A
DUMB BEAT.
>> YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> KEEP ON ROCKING.
>> WHAT'S THE MAIN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ROCK AND RAP?
>> UH, USUALLY SKIN COLOR.
>> ROCK IS SO GOOD TO ME.
>> YEAH.
>> AND RAP.
>> I DON'T THINK HE MEANT TO SAY
THAT.
♪♪♪
I ACTUALLY FEEL LIKE ROCK IS
ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING TO KIND
OF CHANGE THE WHOLE WORLD AND
KIND OF BRINGIN' PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
>> YEAH, WELL THEY --
THEY DO MAKE THE RAP BUT YOU
DON'T LISTEN TO THAT MANY.
>> EXACTLY.
HE GAVE ME A CIGARETTE, 'CAUSE
HE COULD TELL RAP WAS STRESSING
ME OUT.
♪♪♪
>> ACTUALLY THERE WERE SOME
RAPPERS, LIKE KRS-ONE FROM
BOOGIE DOWN PRODUCTION --
>> FEW RAPPERS, DE LA SOUL AND
TRIBE CALLED QUEST, OR
JAMIE FOXX WOULD SING AND THEN
KANYE WEST WOULD RAP --
A SUMMER I STAYED IN
MADISON, WISCONSIN.
AND THEN I STAYED IN THIS SMALL
TOWN CALLED NEW GLARUS, WHICH
WAS OUTSIDE OF MADISON.
BUT MADISON --
>> ROCK IS JUST AMAZING THOUGH.
AND I THINK IT'S GOING TO BRING
BACK THE COUNTRY.
>> WISCONSIN, AND MADISON
ESPECIALLY --
>> THIS GUY KNEW HIS STUFF.
WE SPOKE FOR FOUR MORE HOURS.
THEN I REMEMBERED I HAD WORK TO
DO.
SO WHAT'S SO GOOD ABOUT RAP?
THIS RAP MUSIC, WHY DO PEOPLE
LIKE IT?
>> IT'S VERSATILE.
>> IT'S POWERFUL, IT'S VISCERAL.
>> THE BEAT IS VERY ENTICING.
>> IT HAS A MESSAGE THAT SPEAKS
TO THE YOUTH.
>> JUST AS I EXPECTED, NO ONE
HAD A SINGLE SMART THING TO SAY
ABOUT RAP.
BUT OUT OF NOWHERE I HAD THIS
CRAZY THOUGHT.
>> I WONDER WHY NOBODY'S EVER
TRIED TO PUT THEM TOGETHER --
YOU KNOW, ROCK AND RAP?
I WONDER IF THAT WOULD WORK.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY BEEN
DONE MUCH, IF AT ALL.
IT'D BE INTERESTING.
I'D GIVE IT A SHOT LISTENING TO
IT.
>> ROCK AND RAP.
HAD A NICE RING TO IT.
I HAD MORE INVESTIGATING TO DO.
NOBODY'S EVER REALLY COMBINED
THE TWO TOGETHER, ROCK AND RAP.
>> YEAH, I GUESS LIKE RUN DMC
BACK IN THE DAY.
>> RUM DMZ?
I SEARCHED IT ON THE INTERNET.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
THIS GUY MUST HAVE BEEN ON
PILLS.
I DECIDED TO PUT THIS ORIGINAL
NEW GENRE TO THE TEST.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
INTRODUCING ROCK 'N' RAP.
>> WHEN DO I START?
♪♪♪
♪ YOU THINK THAT I'M
UNDER YOUR CONTROL
>> GO --
NEVER, EVER --
♪ BITTER
BETTER
SEVER THE TIES ♪
♪ YOU THINK THAT I'M
YOUR LITTLE TOY ♪
♪ OPEN ME UP
PLAY WITH ME
I'M BROKEN INSIDE ♪
>> WOW.
IT SOUNDED INCREDIBLE.
EVERYONE AGREED.
MAYBE NOW THE WORLD WILL BE A
BETTER PLACE.
'CAUSE THERE'S ONE THING THAT
UNITES US ALL -- ROCK 'N' RAP.